c'est à la fin des années 80 que Florent
Pagny se fait connaître du grand public
quelques années plus tard il enchaîne
les succès parvient à vendre des
millions de disques et s'impose parmi
les chanteurs préférés des français avec
un style qui lui est propre
liberté de penser mais l'année dernière
alors qu'il devait partir en tournée
Florent Pagny fait une annonce
bouleversante à ses fans sur les réseaux
sociaux on vient de me diagnostiquer
une tumeur au poumon et tandis
qu'aujourd'hui les chanteurs va beaucoup
mieux ses proches sont revenus sur ses
35 années de carrière et ont dévoilé des
anecdotes inédites dans le documentaire
Florent Pagny un homme libre des fusées
hier sur TF1 il parlait pas il vomissait
et ça le rendait malade la maladie ses
amours son exil retour sur les
révélations du documentaire sur Florent
Pagny
merci d'être là vous avez peut-être vous
êtes autour du livre Florent Pagny la
liberté de chanter alors on va revenir
sur ce documentaire on va revenir par
exemple sur ils sont venus ils sont
venus sur les plus grands moments de la
vie de l'artiste et il y a beaucoup de
gens qui ont dit pourquoi faire un
documentaire Florent Pagny et ben va
mieux et toujours vivant et c'est voilà
moi j'adore Florent Pagny en plus que
au-delà de ça c'est un personnage
incroyable voilà c'est un mec qui a qui
disent qu'il pense il suspent j'adore ce
mec il trace il en a rien à de
tout le monde il fait sa vie il a jamais
dit du mal de personnes ni du bien de
personnes en fait il fait sa vie il fait
son truc et c'est pour ça que j'adore ce
mec voilà Florent Pagny j'ai toujours
kiffé et c'est vrai qu'il en fait il
s'en fout là il a jamais parlé de nous
ni de pas parler ni il s'en fout il fait
sa vie c'est vrai c'est ça c'est ça
c'est quelqu'un qui est à la fois
authentique et qui qui est libre c'est
ça il fait sa vie il emmerde personne
non mais c'est vrai et alors il y a
beaucoup de gens qui qui ont dit voilà
pourquoi faire un documentaire c'est
Gilles est énervé parce qu'il dit pour
faire un documentaire il est il est pas
mort l'impression d'un hommage posthume
pas du tout moi j'ai été extrêmement
choquée parce que j'espère qu'il va très
bien qu'il va se remettre j'espère qu'il
va très bien
mais là j'ai pas du tout compris l'angle
du documentaire pourquoi je documentaire
aujourd'hui on avait vraiment
l'impression que tous ces gens célébrer
quelqu'un qui est là ça aurait disparu
ce qui n'est pas du tout le cas donc ça
m'a profondément choqué moi le
documentaire il a été réalisé par Michel
yonkélévitch en de ces meilleurs amis
donc je vous dis déjà c'est c'est bien
déjà ça tout dit quand c'est un mec qui
essaie c'est un intime voilà c'est un
intime c'est fini tu vois il va pas
faire un truc contre lui et sa femme
dedans absolument tout le contraire de
gilberté j'ai trouvé le documentaire
absolument exceptionnel j'ai trouvé pas
de Patos gratuit j'ai trouvé qu'il y
avait plein de révélations on voit le
parcours d'un gars qui est juste
incroyable liberté de penser liberté de
Chantilly
et pardon mais il y a sa femme qui est
là qui est la deuxième star du
documentaire regardez justement il y
avait des images du début de sa carrière
Florent Pagny regardez c'est moi le 27
mai 1982 il apparaît pour la première
fois à la télévision sur Antenne 2 dans
Télé folie ambitieux il ne compte pas
s'arrêter là au début de l'année 1988 la
France découvre le nouveau visage de
Florent Pagny fini l'acteur place au
chanteur aidez ses premières apparitions
c'est un carton Florent Pagny a eu
raison de croire en ton destin n'importe
quoi et disque d'or avec 700 000
exemplaires vendus
cette chanson lui permet même de
remporter une victoire de la musique
comme révélation masculine de l'année
et ce qu'on aimait également les gens
c'est qu'il y avait des révélations sur
ces histoires d'amour les plus grandes
polémiques aussi autour du chanteur ils
ont parlé de tout exactement regardez
ils ont parlé notamment de son histoire
d'amour avec Vanessa Paradis
Florent Pagny est un jeune homme très
entouré mais reste un cœur à prendre
c'est lors du tournage d'une émission de
télévision qu'il va avoir un coup de
foudre il est invité à chanter son
nouveau single dans l'émission le voyage
magique à Disney World un programme de
variété tourné en Floride auquel
participent de nombreux artistes dont
une certaine Vanessa Paradis dès leur
première rencontre Florent Pagny et
subjugué par la chanteuse il ne le sait
pas encore mais ce coup de foudre et
réciproque et un matin je
descends j'arrive dans sa chambre et là
j'hallucine je vois la tête de Vince à
mardi et là je mais je suis dans la
chute carrément pétrif je suis gêné je
m'en vais quoi
elle avait 15 ans lui il en avait 25
ans
et 27 ans mais après c'est vrai que
notre époque est devenue beaucoup plus
prude à ce niveau là mais à cette époque
là c'était pas 157 ans ça choquait pas
choqué
alors il y a une histoire c'est une
histoire qui va être fait beaucoup
parler à l'époque le couple avait été
obligé de déménager chez toi harcèlement
n'est pas paradis regardez
je me souviens d'une anecdote où Vanessa
donc dormez à la maison en bas et
commencer à y avoir des photographes
donc vous n'avez pas les fenêtres en
bleu pour pas que les gens voient dans
la maison voilà il est à un moment de sa
vie là où
il est suivi scruté et pieds violets
[Musique]
c'est ce que lui il ressent même si le
couple tente de se faire plus discret la
presse s'acharne un article publié dans
le magazine Rolling Stones sous-entend
qu'il aurait initié Vanessa Paradis à
des plaisirs interdits des mots qui
déclenchent aussitôt la fureur du
chanteur alors c'est quoi cette histoire
tout simplement il a été poursuivi
pendant
les années où il était pendant laquelle
il était avec Vanessa Paradis par les
paparazzi effectivement et aussi par une
certaine presse
une certaine presse bien prendante
uroling Stones
libération qui revient là-dessus
justement et qui dit bah ouais on l'a
défoncé en fait on avait tort c'est bien
de dire c'est bien d'ailleurs presque
qui roule ça ça fait référence à Roger
presque qui roule voilà
une reprise peut-être alors sa rupture
avec la chanteuse celle qui l'a quitté
au cours de l'été 91 a été le début de
la descente aux enfers du chanteur ça
c'est un coup très dur pour lui il a
tout il a pris il a eu il a eu divers
malheurs qui sont arrivés qui sont
battus sur lui regarde
à peine 3 ans après le succès de
n'importe quoi Florent Pagny et ruiné
les
dates pires il fait l'objet d'un
redressement fiscal pour ne rien
arranger son couple avec Vanessa Paradis
bas de l'aile déprimé après une soirée
trop arrosée Florent Pagny finit à
l'hôpital américain à Neuilly-sur-Seine
et il n'était pas bien il faisait un
burn out il était fatigué il était
stressé il n'en pouvait plus au cœur de
l'été 1991 Vanessa Paradis le quitte
c'est un violent qui a convaincre de
gens qui tournent la veste se retrouvent
très sales alors au plus bas Florent
Pagny rencontre un homme qui va devenir
l'un de ses meilleurs amis quand j'ai
rencontré il dormait pratiquement dans
sa bagnole quoi c'est l'époque où il se
fait planter par tout le monde alors là
descente aux enfers
des saisies sur sur ses cachets il bah
du coup il avait s'est retrouvé presque
son domicile fixe et en plus les deux
carrières
n'hésitez pas à peu près parallèle la
carrière de Vanessa Paradis à la
carrière de Florent Pagny c'est ça
n'était plus parallèle quoi c'est à dire
que Vanessa Paradis prenait de plus en
plus un quart d'heure de Vanessa Paradis
pour les de plus en plus d'ampleur
tandis que celle de Florent Pagny sont
restés ou pas les appareils en fait j'ai
cru comprendre qu'il qui se voyait plus
trop
mais après après quelque chose qui reste
et une autre femme qui est beaucoup mise
en avant dans ce documentaire c'est
azukena Kamano la Femme Actuelle de
Florent Pagny celle qui l'a sauvé de
cette descente aux enfers regarde
à la fin de cette terrible année 1992 le
chanteur est invité à un dîner c'est là
qu'il rencontre pour la première fois la
mannequin et artiste peintre Argentine à
soussena
Kardashian
je me présente et en serrant la main il
me tire la main je sais ce qui c'est là
qui me tire la main c'est pas ni oh là
là panique alors c'était il y avait tout
faux en fait
et voilà voilà notre première rencontre
la jeune femme ne seront pas compte mais
ce soir-là Florent Pagny succombe
immédiatement j'ai découvert une
personne super qui m'a vraiment séduit
après avec tous ces maladroites
c'est vrai que ce qu'elle raconte c'est
en fait il a il a dragué quoi il est
tombé amoureux d'elle tout de suite coup
de foudre mais il sait pas de c'est pas
que c'est quelqu'un qui sait pas dragué
donc il s'est ramassé un petit peu un
vent et puis après elle a découvert quel
homme il était
alors et après ils ont Montréal c'est
quelqu'un de c'est rare des hommes qui
sont aussi fidèles qui est fidèle en
amitié c'est vrai qu'il a pas eu
énormément de d'histoire d'amour tu vois
pas dans les côtés c'est vrai que voilà
mais en tout cas je fais un gros bisou à
je suis en panique et ils ont montré le
déménagement qui avait fait polémique à
l'époque aussi il est parti en Patagonie
je sais même pas que ça existait la
Patagonie je crois que c'est une sorte
de pâte et en fait grâce à grâce à
Florent Pagny c'était un pays qui
regardent c'est sur les terres de la
jeune femme en Patagonie au sud de
l'Argentine que le couple par
s'installer à la surprise générale j'ai
arrivé à un moment de ma vie avec la
notoriété où je saturé un petit peu de
ça ou ou j'arrivais plus à gérer le de
l'autre côté connu et ça ça commençait à
me monter au cerveau et en venant ici
j'ai senti que je trouvais un équilibre
donc que j'allais pouvoir et vivre ma
notoriété sainement sans péter un câble
sans me prendre pour un autre et
en même temps être moi-même personne au
milieu de rien
[Applaudissements]
dans un instant et ce qu'on a pu voir
aussi dans ce documentaire si on a pu
voir quelques images du combat de
Florent Pagny contre la maladie sa femme
notamment dévoilé les coulisses du
tournage de la vidéo dans laquelle le
chanteur annonce son concert on a tous
vu cette vidéo regardez
avec les chimiothérapies qui s'annoncent
le chanteur ne va pas pouvoir reprendre
sa tournée des 60 ans qu'il venait de
commencer
reste à l'annoncer à ses fans et là il
commence à répéter sans son discours il
va raconter à son public qui avait un
qui a un cancer alors il commence à
faire son truc 5 minutes des vidéos si
jamais ça va pas comment ça va donner
des détails mais presque qui me
donnaient les noms des laboratoires je
dis ça va pas non tu résumes et là les
enfants d'ignorent papa un message
Instagram pas plus 20 minutes il était
cru il était dur mais il était sincère
c'était ce qui voulait faire comment il
va aujourd'hui la flore il semblerait
qu'il aille mieux déjà il avait fait une
première vidéo en juin à peu près pour
pour dire que ça ça tumeur qui avait la
taille au départ d'un kiwi mais c'était
chimiothérapie avait tellement bien
marché que c'était résorbée c'était
résorbé elle avait
la taille d'une noix